und dann haben wir hier eine kuchen
möchte man lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer weiteren folge
der minecraft commons eigentlich sollte
dieses video gestern kommen nur hatte
ich gestern hat so gar keine zeit
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich
mache heute einfach ein zweites video
mit dem command weil ich hab mir wieder
51 rausgesucht und die sind alle ganz
nice und wir fangen sie kennt es ja
schon meistens ist es so dass der erste
command einfach immer nur sowas simples
ist und so weiter und so fort bis dann
der fünfte so den kompletten rahmen ein
versprechen das ich will nicht sagen er
sprengt den rahmen aber ich arbeite mich
so langsam hoch und der erste band
wurden auf jeden fall erstmal zugesendet
von sos 6er ein ender drache der mich
nur anschaut und auf einer stelle die
ganze zeit bleibt also ich gebe diesen
command ein zusammen ändert reagan dann
mit dieser welle in der mitte +20 also
ich meine höhe
da ist die höhe vom ende dragon haare
sind kaká letztens erst beim friseur
aber ich muss ich glaub ich schon wieder
hin
jedenfalls dann gebe ich drück einfach
mal enter und dann seht ihr schon wo ich
die ränder drache da ist er jetzt nicht
beispielsweise mal einfach hier hoch
fliege und die stäbe stelle mich hierhin
seht ihr schon jeden moment der dreht
sich gleich doch peter der pkw nicht zu
werden oder ok freunde ich weiß gar
nicht wollen dass liegt vorhin der test
welt was soll also der der bleibt
natürlich nur auf einer stelle aber der
sollte mich auch eigentlich anschauen
ich probiere das ganze jetzt mal eben
über einen dings hier zu machen über
einen command blog aber eigentlich
sollte der wenn ich um den rumpf liege
sollte der nur mich anschauen
ich habe gerade überhaupt keinen plan
wie wieso die einfach nur die ganze zeit
in eine richtung schauen so neue welt
neues glück sammeln ender dragon da ist
schäfer ich flieg hoch in jeans laden
und jetzt jetzt haben wir als freunde
jetzt ist wohl irgendwie an der welt
also jetzt habe ich den mit dem gleichen
command gesprochen ihr seht schon hier
oder wenn ich mal einfach mal hoch gehe
das ist einfach dieser command und ihr
seht schon der schaut mich jetzt an an
welchen wenn ich mich herum
ihr schaut er mich die ganze zeit
einfach nur an egal wo ich mich hin
dreher und übrigens nenn ich mal durch
die wolken durch schaue sehe ich gerade
da ist da gar nicht mehr der nebel
kommen jetzt haben wir hier noch so
einen sondereffekt mit drin von
effektvoll wie stumpfe einfach davon
nebel aber wenn ich dadurch cook ist
kein nebel eigentlich ich finde
eigentlich cola mit nebel also hier
gerade in der winter in der winterlichen
bio zeit hier also ihr seht schon das
ist einfach ein ender drachenboot mit zu
sehen von sos 6er der auf der gleichen
stelle fliegt und er mich die ganze zeit
anguckt egal wo ich hinfliegen und das
vakuum einst und jetzt kommt's mir zu
command nummer tempomat nummer zwei
wurde mir zugesendet von congstar hd und
zwar ist es eine recht simple sache mal
wieder und hhg montag um die telekom und
leuchtet hier den bäckern oder aber das
ist nicht das thema sondern commander 2
handelt von einem befehl der krippe bzw
anderem ops in nur einem gewissen
umkreis tötet also sagen wir mal ich
habe hier ganz viele creeper allerdings
möchte ich nur diese krippe töten und
nicht den einen krieg den ich oben auf
dem berg habe und den möchte auch nicht
töten indem ich auch nicht töten
außer der kommt jetzt natürlich zu mir
hin gelaufen dann wird er vielleicht
doch sterben und zwar gebe ich jetzt
einfach mal in den chat ein kill at also
entity type creeper und er gleich und
dieses er gleich bestimmt den radius
also er gleich ist jetzt gleich fünf das
heißt alle creeper im radius von fünf
jahren getötet ich drücke jetzt mal
enter dann seht ihr hier ist tot der
rund 15 block entfernt ist hier noch
keiner gestorben sind alle einfach
weggelaufen aber die da oben sind noch
am leben ich zeig euch nochmal hier drei
creeper achtet auf dem hintergrund und
auf die vorne ich drücke enter die vorne
sterben und die da hinten nicht aber er
bewegt sich jetzt langsam hin und er
wird wahrscheinlich gleich auch in den
eher fünf radius kommen und ich kann
dann auch ganz einfach sagen dass ich
beispielsweise mal hier seien paprika-
hinsetze und den radius dann
beispielsweise auf 15 setzt und dann
werden die da hinten hat auch getötet
bzw wenn ich jetzt mal sage radius 100
dann seht ihr das auch die da oben
einfach tot sind also eine ganz simple
sache dass wenn ihr die ganze box bei
euch habt nicht alle auf der ganzen welt
tötet sondern einfach dieses was muss
man dahinter setze ich glaube ja genau
komme gleich und dann hat man da dann
einfach ein radiomann einfügen kann
aufnahme bestimmten
ein
was wollte ich sagen in einem bestimmten
umkreis kann man dann die gewissen mops
töten das geht nicht nur mit clip an das
geht doch mit zombies oder mit schiebe-
oder mit karo oder mit blaze oder mit
place ich was ist da sonst so als
schicken und so weiter und so fort und
david roman nummer drei wurde mir zu
gesänge von christie's ix und zwar meint
er beziehungsweise sie ich weiß mir
christian männer oder ein frau name ist
dass das ganze eine rotten flesh
maschine darstellt ich mache es mal
wieder hier so ein paar fackeln hin
ich finde da sieht es ganz cool aus und
vor allem die beleuchtung der fackeln
wie damit er freue sich schon alles aus
da kommt ihnen was man kann irgendwie
auf einer gewissen entfernung jetzt
sieht man das schon kann man durch die
fackel so ein paar komische sachen sehen
oder bin ich kann jedenfalls bonn ich
jetzt hier ein paar zombies und wenn ich
jetzt in den chat eingebe zusammen
village riding wille golem
das heißt ich spanne das ganze jetzt und
wir sehen hier einen villiger der einen
golem bereitet und der golem attackiert
ja wie jeder weiß der attackiert zombies
und jetzt gehen nämlich die ganzen
zombies im umkreis bewegen sich jetzt
auf diesen villiger zu weil sie halt nur
den villagers sehen und zombies wollen
ja billiger töten allerdings reitet der
willicher einen golem das heißt der
golem sieht dann aber kommt ein zombie
an weil der zombie in diesem village
oder verknallt ist aber dann tötet der
wille der vita cola bietet dann halt den
zombie und das ist halt eigentlich
megane eis und es ist eine robbenfleisch
maschine bzw
nicht mehr rotten flesh sondern auch so
eine gewisse erfahrung experience
maschine oder irgendwie so wie man zeit
bitten möchte das heißt einfach wenn ich
diesen command eingebe gehen automatisch
die ganzen vom bis zum winter hin weil
sie den bilder sehen allerdings war der
voyager einen golem reiter tötet der
golem dann die zombies der golem
irgendwann studiert aber extrem viel
leben einfach so das dauert ein weilchen
und das stellt dann so eine art rotten
flesh maschine da kann man ganz simpel
zusammenbauen beziehungsweise einfach
diesen command anwenden wurden wir
zugesendet von christie's cx und jetzt
kommen wir zu command freunde mit shader
ich kann's ich sag's einfach nur in
jeder folge ist die zu unfassbar schön
wenn ich ganz schnell switche ich weiß
nicht ob man es bei youtube sieht aber
dann kommen so komische grafikfehler
keine ahnung wer die kommen aber das
objekt nur wenn ich ganz schnell wird
yahoo mahnte hier wurde im zuge von
newroz heimen erst bund nämlich viele
kleine kompakte bin ziemlich kleine aber
das ist auf jeden fall schon mal der
command den kann ich hier einfach so ein
geben da sehen wir schon dass da extrem
extrem extrem extrem viele sachen drin
stehen ihr seht die ganzen kommerz
übrigens in der beschreibung
ihr könnt dann einfach wohl hier skala
steht könnte kontrast einfach durch euro
minecraft namen ersetzen oder durch in
den anderen minecraft namen und ich sehe
das licht der face kam es eigentlich
geht man ganz cool ein täglich auf jeden
fall einfach mal auf fertig packe hier
eine nicht eine fackel ich brauche dafür
einen hebel dann packe ich da einen
hebel dran und ihr seht schon was jetzt
gespannt wird ist ein monster stoner und
hallo also dieser monster's ball quasi
einfach villagers die meinen kopf auf
haben und dementsprechend andere kleine
konkreter sind alter ich habe meine
eigene kleine armee guckt euch das mal
an dass sich amerika knuffig aus alter
wie cool
guckt mal rüber freundlich möchten
spleen schott machen hallo freunde die
verleben sich christ euch com ist euch
ja ja ja
also freunde mit hilfe des commands
denen der beschreibung als vierter
command betitelt seht könnt ihr damit
quasi eure eigene kleine armee
erschaffen
die wird dann so alle 10 sekunden oder
so kommt darauf an wie oft dieses borner
das ganze bond wird das dann gesprochen
sondern seht ihr schon dass hier ganz
viele läufer comedia sogar noch erzählt
dass dann ganz viele kleine kontraste
gespannt werden
in den anderen namen eingibt kommt dann
halt ein anderer kopf bei raus und ein
anderer titel und so weiter und so fort
und ja das ist 4,5 sport etwas recht
simples aber trotzdem irgendwie
verstörendes und zwar einen
verkrüppelten ändern
das wird mir zu gesendet von marcel z
und zwar meint er ja das ist ein ändern
der hat nicht seinen kopf da wo sein
kopf normalerweise ist sondern wenn ich
mal den command eingebe der hat seinen
korb gar nicht der hat nämlich seinen
kopf da ein
in seinem körper und der bewegt sich
nicht bis ich ihn schlage weil dann
teleportiert der dich dann kommt der pc
wieder daher schnell wieder schlagen und
dann kommt der pizzeria dann schlag ich
nehmen und dann kommt der pc wieder
freunde
ich weiß nicht wieso es gibt einfach
mega creepy aus finde ich es sieht so
noch viel kritiker aus als seien
endermann an sich schon aussieht
normalerweise hatte den kopf hier oben
drauf aber der hat irgendwie den kopf in
seinem körper und das kann man auf jeden
fall mit diesem command spawnen motion
ganz ganz komische sachen mit rotation
und im tief bis zu der geschwungenen
klammer verstehe ich noch alles was da
drinsteht verstehe ich nicht süßes
brötchen willst du mal seine augen sind
einfach so total als wenn er wirklich
sondern der intelligenteste tierfreunde
dass es auf jeden fall command nummer 5
der zu gesendet wurde von marcel dann
kann dich marcel sieht auf jeden fall
schon mega creepy aus wenn ihr auch
solche simplen oder komplizierten oder
irgendwelche halt total einfachen
command sich aber sind irgendwelche
zusagen creepy sachen hinzufügen sowie
das mit diesem ändern wären hier einfach
gehabt dann seht ihr unten der
beschreibung den ersten link über meinem
ganzen netzwerken und den link zu meinem
mikro und den ganzen anderen sachen seht
ihr einen link zu dem commands formular
wo ihr euch nicht anmelden muss sondern
einfach auch im namen eintragen und aus
dem command eintragen und kurz sagen was
der macht und dann haben wir hier eine
kuh
da würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr mir da
ein paar command zusendet und dann würde
ich sagen wenn es euch gefallen hat
würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen
ich gehe jetzt mal ein geburtstag noch
feiern und ich dachte grad schon da
hinten sports am hexenhaus aber dass man
nur ein berg und dann sehen uns in der
nächsten folge wieder wenn es wieder
heißt luca stellt marke gemeint